i want to read this article if you can
go to this article
so uh uh zoom in
refresh because for whatever reason it
just got blurry okay there you go where
wamu went wrong okay and this is uh uh
sea as a seattle times yeah seattle time
so if you can zoom in a little bit zoom
in zoom in zoom in zoom and zoom in a
little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more
okay now center it okay keep going up
keep going up keep going up
okay the stock is on 71 percent over the
past year go up to see exactly what the
date is i think this is uh sometime in
oh wait
yeah april 14 2008 okay keep going down
there's four things i want to read here
keep going down keep going down keep
going down keep going down keep going
down
okay here we go so a few reasons why
wamu um
uh why why what woman went wrong woman
aggressively stepped up its lending in
some of the riskiest loan types
short-term adjustable rate mortgages
especially so-called option arm
home equity loans and line of credit and
some prime loans over the past four
years
more than half of the real estate loans
woman made were in one of these higher
risk categories that's a massive number
woman made billions of dollars worth of
loans with only limited documentation of
borrower's income
uh net worth or credit history such as
often called liar loans i've never heard
of that before but ninja loans i've
heard many times no income no job no
assets okay that's what we call it nina
makeup of three quarters of the 59
billion dollars option arm
then next one complaints from appraisers
and investigation by new york attorney
general said one will lend leaned on
appraisers to inflate property value to
support bigger mortgages okay
uh uh that's pretty deep for you to even
know that because i don't even know how
you're going to control that part so
okay fine let's just say that's part of
it whoever maybe the you know the guy
that's writing it
speculating a little bit too much in
august 2004 one will loosen the standard
for front money to fronting money to
third-party mortgage brokers allow
brokers with heavier debt loads to make
more loans is this would this be best
described as correspondence is that the
correspondence like the way they're
describing it
sounds like it okay so in correspondence
do you know how correspondence works or
no no i don't guys were making money on
correspondence so guys were making three
four five hundred thousand dollars a
month in la they were getting paid
behind like so you say you're getting
your two percent or three percent or
four big mac say they capped it at two
percent many of these banks it's not
just one more many people were doing it
on the back end you could get another
half a point or a point or point and a
half correspondence
on a lot of mice a lot of money these
are these are mortgage brokers you're
saying these this is when guys had four
you know you know phantoms for no reason
and they could afford to have four
phantoms but keep going down there's a
part i want to read keep going a little
lower
uh here you go that's the part right
there as a result at the end of the last
year more than 56
this is my this is my concern
carry here 56 of wamu's loan portfolio
that's 138.4 billion dollars consisted
of option arms
home equity loans and subprimes one
analyst estimates
that largely due to such loans more than
16 billion in future losses are embedded
in wamu's book so when i see a number
like 56 percent woman loan portfolio as
an option arm
that is i mean
i understand being this this is again my
concern i understand being aggressive
but this is like
you know we're going for it
when you see an article like this being
written with this kind of data i mean
you know this you saw this article that
was 14 years ago it's not like you're
not aware this article that was written
but when you see numbers like this what
do you think now 14 years later
well again um i think that first of all
there are several parts of the article i
would disagree with just factually but i
remember washington mutual was required
to have about two-thirds of its assets
and residential based as i mentioned
earlier it was it was very difficult if
not impossible to hold fixed-rate loans
in portfolio you basically would have to
sell those because you couldn't take on
the risk of
of the impact on the portfolio of rising
interest rates of holding a fixed rate
so we we held
most of the option arms
remember that product was only sold to
prime customers
it had a loan to value ratio of about 70
percent did not have significant
negative amortization in it the other
products such as uh
home equity loans were predominantly uh
to uh to prime customers as well and
they're basically home equity loans that
nobody use helocs yeah he locks
basically fine i i can understand that
one understanding but subprime and
option arm that's 56 that's a big number
if you look if i look at that right now
like
riverside county you remember riverside
county what it was like i mean i had an
office in riverside so i used to go to
riverside all the time
64
were in
flint
you're walking through you're like what
the hell is going on here and most of
these people bought i'm not saying they
bought it from you they bought it from
countrywide they bought it from new
century they bought it from there's a
bunch of these guys but but
56
is is
here's here's my other concern while you
guys are selling this wall street's
buying it on the back end are they
buying the paper for you or you're
sitting on the paper
well again we would sell
option arms as well as fixed rate loans
to both fannie mae freddie mac and wall
street so so you have those percentages
that were indicated but during that
period we were
decreasing that portfolio fairly
significantly so a lot of that was from
things that were in the past now
remember that it would not be unusual
for the thrift like the thrifts we
acquired in california they probably had
80 to 90 percent of their assets would
be in
in residential
loans and most if not all of that would
be option arms i mean that was the
principal product in in california now
again that product i won't disagree i
mean it was
slightly riskier
than
than fixed rate and so we knew that but
you were getting paid to take on that
some additional risk but they again were
you tried to mitigate that with it only
going to uh but to prime customers so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]